♪♪
THE BOMB SUIT CAN
WITHSTAND A BLAST FROM UP
TO 5 KILOGRAMS OF C4
FROM 3 METERS AWAY.
ONE OF THE KEY INGREDIENTS
THAT GOES INTO A BOMB SUIT
IS A MATERIAL CALLED KEVLAR.
KEVLAR IS AN EXAMPLE OF
A SUPER-STRONG ARAMID POLYMER.
IT'S MADE BY
MANIPULATING MOLECULES
SO THAT THEY BOND TOGETHER
IN PARALLEL LINES,
FORMING AN INCREDIBLY
STRONG MATERIAL.
IT TAKES A GREAT DEAL OF ENERGY
FOR A PROJECTILE TO PASS
THROUGH THE FABRIC
BECAUSE THE POLYMER MOLECULES
ARE EXTREMELY HARD
TO PUSH APART.
A PROJECTILE HAS
ITS ENERGY STOLEN FROM IT
AS IT TRIES TO FIGHT
ITS WAY THROUGH.
Narrator: ANOTHER CRUCIAL
LAYER OF PROTECTION
IS THE BLAST PLATE.
IF THERE IS A BOMB
THAT EXPLODES IN FRONT OF YOU,
THERE'S A SHOCK WAVE
THAT COMES OUT FROM IT.
AND THIS BLAST PLATE
WILL PROTECT YOU.
THE BLAST PLATE IS MADE OF STEEL
AND IS CANTILEVERED
SO THAT YOU CAN HAVE FLEXIBILITY
IN BENDING OVER
TO REACH THE BOMB.
AN ILL-FITTING SUIT
COULD INHIBIT YOUR FLEXIBILITY.
AND YOU NEED TO BE
REALLY FLEXIBLE AND NIMBLE
TO DO THE DELICATE TASK
OF DEACTIVATING A BOMB.
THE OUTER LAYER'S
CALLED THE CARRIER.
AND IT'S MADE OF NOMEX,
WHICH IS
A FIRE-RETARDANT POLYMER.
IT'S ANOTHER ARAMID POLYMER
LIKE KEVLAR.
BUT INSTEAD OF BEING
RESISTANT TO PUNCTURE,
IT'S RESISTANT TO HEAT.
Narrator: NOMEX IS A VERY POOR
CONDUCTOR OF HEAT
AND WILL NOT MELT OR DRIP.
ALTHOUGH IT WILL IGNITE,
IT TAKES ABOUT TWICE
AS LONG AS COTTON TO CATCH FIRE.
AND WHEN THE HEAT IS REMOVED,
IT IMMEDIATELY STOPS BURNING.
THESE BOMBS SUITS ARE OBVIOUSLY
BULKY, AS THEY SHOULD BE.
YOU'RE TRYING NOT
TO GET BLOWN UP.
AGAIN, THAT'S
THE ESSENTIAL THING
WITH THESE BOMBS SUITS --
DON'T GET BLOWN UP.
SINCE THE SUITS WEIGH
AROUND 70 POUNDS,
E.O.D. TECHNICIANS
HAVE TO BE TESTED
TO PROVE THEY CAN
CARRY THE WEIGHT.
I WOULD TOTALLY
TRY ON A BOMB SUIT.
I WOULDN'T GO NEAR
ANY BOMBS IN IT,
BUT I WOULD
DEFINITELY TRY ONE ON.
I SHARE MY BOMB SUIT
WITH EVERYBODY ON MY TEAM,
WHICH IS USUALLY
TWO TO THREE OTHER PEOPLE.
YOU SWEAT A LOT.
Haislip: UH, ON THE OTHER HAND,
IF A GUY HAD BEEN
WEARING IT OUT IN THE SUN,
I'D REALLY HAVE TO LIKE HIM
TO PUT THAT SUIT ON.
ONE THING THAT'S INTERESTING
ABOUT A BOMB-SUIT GLOVE,
WHEN YOU FIRST SEE IT,
YOU'RE LIKE,
"OH, IS THAT INVISIBLE?"
AND, NO, NO. THEY JUST DON'T
WEAR GLOVES A LOT OF THE TIME.
LIKE, WHAT IS UP WITH THAT?
Narrator: THAT'S BECAUSE,
WHEN IT COMES TO BOMB DISPOSAL,
DEXTERITY WITH YOUR HANDS
IS VERY IMPORTANT.
THERE ARE SOME BOMB-SUIT GLOVES.
BUT FOR THE MOST PART,
YOU WANT PRECISION
OVER PROTECTION.
HAVING DEXTERITY
IS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN PROTECTING YOUR DIGITS
FROM A BLAST
BECAUSE, THE MORE DEXTERITY
THAT YOU HAVE,
THE LESS LIKELY IT IS
THAT YOU WOULD HAVE A BLAST.
I THINK IF I HAD AN ACCESSORY
ON A BOMB SUIT
IT WOULD JUST BE, LIKE, A BUTTON
THAT'S JUST A PORTAL INTO SPACE
AND TIME
TO GET ME OUT OF THE SITUATION
AND DOING SOMETHING
ENTIRELY DIFFERENT.